I ain't going to submit to no idea
listen you call this later right now
listen I ain't got time for this up all
wor I don't mean to be me rude or okay
no come on man there you go this Alabama
mechanic had no idea he was about to be
arrested for refusing to turn over his
ID cops arrested Roland Edgar as he
worked on a customer's car in a church
parking lot claiming he violated an
Alabama law that allows cops to demand
your name where you live and what you're
doing when there's a reasonable
suspicion of a crime was he legally
required to turn over his ID nope your
ID has way more information than just
your name and address meaning cops can't
force you to hand it over and a federal
judge agreed ruling the plain text of
the Alabama statute is so clear that no
reasonable officer could have believed
they could arrest Edgar that same judge
also denied the cops qualified immunity
cops often act like they're Invincible
but they're not as the judge put it the
police are free to ask questions and the
public is free to ignore them